the queen killer is still out there
everyone is scared he's a murderer he's
a monster he's perfect
hey
boss
who are you the name's nimona your
Sidekick has arrived I don't need to
decide every villain needs a sidekick
I'm not a villain
the real villain is still out there and
I do need help and then who do you want
to kill first what look I can help you
but promise me you won't freak out why
would I trust you I promise even when
you see the horn I promise promise I
will not agree
this is the part where you run away
you did that on purpose
something something something we win
anyone can find them
it's me they call me
Ambrosius really thinks I'm a murderer
portrayed by someone you trusted because
once everyone sees you as a villain
that's what you are
you saw us
yes
don't Corner that the world kicks you
around sometimes
but together we can kick it back
smart kind and sophisticated
speeds armor
I like where this is going let's break
stuff
promise I'm your official sidekick for
ever and ever no take backsies
can you just be you I don't follow
[Music]
none of this makes sense look boss it's
simple if you like something thumbs up
if you don't like it thumbs down who has
four thumbs and is really great at
liking stuff